again
what is it that you're looking for
answers to
i mean you're successful you've got a
good job
you're in a long-term relationship with
a man that you say that you love
and that he owns you to some degree
although you're unwilling to tattoo
his name on your body so what is it that
you're seeking answers to
um the red pill ideology
like
it to what extent is it correct
and to what extent is it not correct and
if it's not correct
then what what is um what is the truth
everybody everybody has their own
interpretation of what they think is the
truth or correct your truth is not my
truth my truth is not your truth
why truth is completely different from
your truth obviously because
i'm telling you that i trust a woman to
be a woman
but you want me to trust a woman
indefinitely you want me to
throw everything no i don't i don't want
you to feel anything well you're
questioning why
my version of love is different from
yours and i'm telling you it's because
men and women love differently
and when you understand the dynamics
between men and women
then you start to understand how to
apply your time
effort and resources to that
relationship so you get better results
what you're trying to do basically is
you're trying to pull me back under the
reservation
i'm not trying to pull you back onto the
reservation well you don't realize that
you're doing it but what you're trying
to do is you're trying to pull me back
to the feminized you know belief system
the comforting lies that don't serve men
because that's what women will do to
like you read my book so i mean you
heard me talk about the
process of beta tization through a
thousand concessions right
this is what you're trying to do with me
inadvertently you don't understand that
you're doing it you don't see yourself
doing it
the viewers out there that have read my
book and are watching me talk about this
right now are starting to understand
comment below
but what i'm trying to say is that you
are you're subconsciously trying to get
me to subscribe to beliefs and things
that don't serve me
my purpose and let me keep myself as my
own mental point of origin
right because you want things a certain
way that is female solipsism
the inability to see past your own note
knows i mean you said in your email like
i don't understand what the solipsism
thing is and
everything else that follow that but
what you're exhibiting right now is
female solipsism and
you don't see it you don't understand it
because you're a check and that's fine
i love women for it that's totally okay
i'm not expecting you to be different
i'm not expecting you to view the world
you know through the lens that i view it
through
what i'm what i'm saying to you though
is that it's okay that you see things
differently from me
men and women are compliments to one
another if it's allowed
that's all okay
um do you do you wish women were
different
from the world i don't think that they
are no i don't wish women were any
different
i mean i wish we didn't have social
media
you know like i wish we didn't have
women posting selfies all the time on
freaking instagram and
dancing around like monkeys on tick tock
like a bunch of chimps
i wish we didn't have only fans you know
things like that you know i wish that
women didn't have the right to vote
do you wish for a deeper that you could
have a deeper love with women
i already have deep love with women i've
loved many women i have deep love
with women when i have it so okay so
you're
totally happy then is that right my life
is [ __ ] amazing
okay
why is it that you're trying to poke
holes through my life to try to find
something
i'm not trying to poke hold i swear to
god i'm not i wish i wish i could like
prove to you
that i'm not i know that you're
analytical and you're a smart chick but
i mean
what you're doing is you're taking
female nature and you're throwing a
little bit of einstein into it you know
another blender and trying to blend it
up and trying to [ __ ] with me
i'm not trying to [ __ ] with you
um i'd like to feel like the kind of
love you feel and understand what it is
no you don't
maybe maybe maybe i don't want to love
the way that i love you don't
women women need to be women stop see
women trying to be men women trying to
view the world through a man's lens
is not going to serve you be a woman
compliment your man's life tattoo his
name on your body and show him that
you're in it for the long haul
you see what i'm saying here like you're
not the same as me i don't want you to
view the world the way that i view it
i mean if you're interested in what i've
written about if you want to watch my
videos by all means hop in there watch
them all
enjoy it share it with your friends
share with your boyfriend i don't care
but i don't i don't think that women
should apply the lens to which i view
the world to their lives
i mean there's certain things that i i
mean if i were to have a conversation
with my daughter
and she were to say daddy what should i
do when it comes to selecting
a man should i get married like my
conversation with my daughter about
marriage will be different than
if i had a son i would i would
definitely yes absolutely get married
everything is in your favor you have
nothing to lose and everything to gain
just make sure you pick the right guy
you don't pick a douchebag if you need
any help with that
i'm there fine fight a son absolutely
not that is the dumbest thing that you
can do boy
yeah you see what i'm saying all right
yep why is there so much hate
like i don't know
hatred maybe not hatred there there's a
there's a lot of red pill
rage in your audience there is
a lot of guys there's a lot of guys that
take it way too far
and spend way too much time hating on
women because
see i closed my book off like you read
it right to the end did you get right to
the conclusion
yeah the whole point of this book i said
at the end
is not so that you'll hate women it's so
that you'll never hate them for what
they can never be to you
and that's where these black pillar guys
go completely wrong these guys that
focus
all of their energy on looks uh if you
don't look good enough you're never
going to get the girl blah blah blah and
all that kind of stuff and they spend
all kinds of time
with scientific results and look at
johnny depp and brad pitt and all this
kind of [ __ ]
and it's like they go deep down into a
rabbit hole
of hate because they haven't accepted
things for what they are and they
haven't truthfully taken the red pill
right this is my channel in what i talk
about
is one of the few places on youtube that
gives you the cold hard honest truth
that actually gives guys the tools and
resources
if they're willing to do the work on
themselves so men can level up
there's a lot of stuff out there that
doesn't do that though and you're
absolutely right
there is a lot of hatred towards women
and there's a part of me that doesn't
blame a lot of these guys because
they've been lied to
they've been lied to by their parents a
lot of them have been raised by single
moms they've been lied to by school
by religion by culture by hollywood the
list goes on and on
they've been lied to about what the
world's supposed to be and then when
they get out in the real world they
realize that
well i was her friend and she didn't
want to bang me what did i do wrong or
you know they go and do something that
they thought was aligned with what they
were told but it didn't work or they got
their heart broken
that's when they get pissed off and
a lot of these guys don't know how to
deal with rejection they were never
taught how to deal with rejection they
were never taught that it's important
like
like most guys i i guarantee right now
if i were to walk out into a large
public place and i took a survey and i
said
how many of you guys know how to check
the oil on your car how many of you guys
know how to
change a flat tire i guarantee most men
today would
not know what to do with it even if
their life depended on it
yeah they know how to order uber eats
they know how to go and super like some
chick [ __ ] on instagram or
send her money on only fans they know
how to do that but they don't have like
core masculine competency skills
can they build a fire with two matches i
bet a lot of guys couldn't
would they know how to disarm a guy if
you pull a gun on them in an atm
probably not
right this is the kind of [ __ ] that i do
this is the kind of stuff that i talk to
guys about i'm like
guys go and do the work you know you
want to get the girls
unplugged from the bs lies some of the
stuff that
you're trying to get me to see you know
through your own lens
unplug from the lies subscribe to the
stuff that works and go and do the work
and that's what i tell like as much as
you have a little bit of a hard time at
this stage still
believe it or not guys like me are
making men better
oh i completely agree with that
you